uh dwayne i i have to ask you we have
a lot of former dunk champs that are
going to be judges all three of you have
been judges
do you have any advice for the judges
dwyane wade
[Laughter]
you know what you'll be a meme no no it
ain't about that i think just
judge with just the way you want to i
think everybody we when it's we're in
this world right now where everybody
gets a trophy
and every time someone does a dunk it's
like oh it's a 10. it's not a 10.
stop giving out tens that's my advice
it's a dunk you can't get no
that's the main thing yeah you miss a
dunk you can't get a 10. wait one dunk
or like
no okay like dominique
him versus jordan there was only one
dunk missed that whole time
other than that it was on the first try
and that's what that's what really gets
the fang going remember uh birdman
17 to 10. birdman remember that you
can't if you can't complete it and you
can't
you can't do the dump i'm saying my
advice to these youngsters
when you put on the show get it done
right away you don't want to
you don't want to show us something like
like like we've never seen and then you
miss
because now it's like ah are you going
to be there
no yeah i'll be there like for example
what if vince carter would have missed
that dunk that he did it would
yeah you know what i'm saying like sure
it wouldn't have that same eye but like
he walked up slow and he took two three
mile and he did it and that's why
everybody went crazy even me with the
camera i was like damn
you all trying to figure well i want the
same amount of looks
and pressure that you put on us as
judges last year in chicago on the
baseline
as for this year i want you to look at
dominique the way you looked at me
because y'all was good and i was judging
no we were no
no no no sir we were not giving out tens
we have uh twitter weighing in on some
of this dunk conversation
seeing that he's not a judge this year
dwyane wade
i didn't realize i forgot you had such
good turnovers listen d-wade did a great
job of judging
thank you thank you because he kept it
going
both of y'all kept it going we're still
talking about a year later candace we
did our job